and finally new rule now that college
grads are decorating their mortar boards
with messages like thanks mom and dad
and proud of my BS parents of graduates
must also wear mortar boards so they can
send messages back to their kids like
your old room is now an Airbnb empty
nesters have the best sex and hope you
like ramen
well it's graduation time and with that
comes the ritual of commencement
addresses when America's overrated
gasbags and wisdom free celebrities are
invited by star [ __ ] universities to
come to their school and tell a bunch of
spoiled stone debt-laden brats things
like your only limit is your own
imagination and the world will be a
better place for having you in it but I
say why not level with the kids for once
kids you're not the future you can't be
anything you want to be and the only way
you can follow your dreams wherever they
take you is if your dreams involve the
grease trap at Chipotle your parents
just spent a quarter million dollars to
send you two drinking camp and the
average student who takes loans now owes
37 grand and dead cheese if you'd spent
that on a minivan at least you'd have
somewhere to sleep
but cheer up kids cuz if you think it's
bad now take solace in the thought that
in 25 years it's gonna be so much worse
can you imagine what a commencement
address will look like in 2041
crap graduates
it's my castle yeah graduates of the
class of 2014 parents faculty
distinguished guests masculine
identifier z' feminine identifiers and
cyborgs
let me first say what an honor it is to
be here today at the university of
california goldman sachs and to join you
in celebrating such an exciting time to
be alive
20:41 this could be the year that Flint
Michigan's tap water becomes drinkable
again now of course it's easy to get
nostalgic for how things used to be
under the first president Kardashian
back before Canada built a wall to keep
us out
and back when a person starting out in
life could still get a studio apartment
in San Francisco for only 2 million
dollars a month well now that same
apartment is unaffordable for all but
the top executives at Exxon Google &
uppington porn so yes we have problems
the leading cause of death in our
country is going outside driverless cars
still won't pick up black people and 90%
of America's wealth is owned by Katy
Perry but as former president Kanye West
once tweeted yo sometimes stuff just be
like that and you got to deal so true
so true look I'd love to tell you kids
that the world is your oyster but the
oysters are all dead along with almost
all species but when that happened did
we give up and just start eating
jellyfish well yes of course we did what
else could we do I mean we can't all
afford plankton my point is we are
resilient I believe it was former Miami
Dolphins coach Don Shula who said
success is not forever and failure is
not fatal Miami was a city that once
existed in Florida and when it sank did
we panic no we didn't panic because we
don't panic did we panic during the Zika
epidemic of 2018 no and many of the
pinheaded babies born that year have
gone on to become fine Republican
congressman
did we panic when Jesus returned to
earth took one look at us and said [ __ ]
you and left
oh we rallied around president Gaga and
took solace in the words of chief chief
justice McConaughey all right all right
all right back to the air